Public Sénat France 24 et RFI
[Musique]
présent bonjour à tous merci de nous
rejoindre pour ici l'Europe nous prenons
cette semaine la direction du Luxembourg
le 2è plus petit État de l'Union
européenne avec à peine 2600 km car à
peine 660000 habitants le Luxembourg est
pourtant le pays le plus riche au monde
selon le classement réalisé par le Fond
Monétaire International avec un produit
brut par habitant autour de 130000 €
trois fois CELI de la France c'est un
pays d'ailleurs fondateur de l'Union
européenne Eurofil pilier du bénéuxe et
nous avons le plaisir de recevoir
aujourd'hui son premier ministre Xavier
Bettel bonjour vous êtes en duplexe
justement du Luxembourg avec nous euh
vous êtes euh donc un homme politique
libérale à la tête d'une coalition qui
regroupe les socialistes et les Verts ça
pourrait changer lors des prochaines
élections on va en parler mais j'ai
envie de vous demander euh pour
commencer depuis le cœur de l'Europe où
vous vous trouvez en ce moment euh
comment vous sentez cette rentrée pour
notre union il y a des grands défis
devant nous que ce soit la migration que
ce soit la guerre en Ukraine euh que ce
soit aussi les challenges économiques et
donc une certaine excitation mais d'un
côté aussi un certain stress parce que
je sais que certains pays quand je parle
de migration veulent pas être solidaire
quand je parle d'économie veulent pas
être solidaire non plus et point de vue
économie on a des chiffres qui viennent
ces jours-ci de l'Allemagne comme quoi
que l'économie fonctionnerait moins bien
il faut savoir que si l'Allemagne a une
un rhume beaucoup de notre économie
risque d'avoir une grippe mais juste
pour reprendre parce qu'on parle
d'économie comme vous avez dit qu'on
était le pays le plus riche au monde
selon la FM je dois juste nuancer quand
même c'est pas que je veux m'excuser ou
quoi que ce soit là-dessus mais c'est
que en fait le calcul est fait par
nombre d'habitants et au Luxembourg vous
avez plus de 200000 frontaliers qui
viennent de Belgique de France et de lux
et d'Allemagne qui viennent travailler
au grand Duchet de Luxembourg et eux ne
sont pas comptés dans ce calcul de ce
qui est produit nationalement donc le
calcul serait déjà bien autre alors nos
téléspectateurs ne le savent pas
nécessairement mais les élections
législatives du Grand Ducher du
Luxembourg auront lieu le 8 octobre 2023
un seul tour hein pour ce scrutin dans
un pays qui a l'habitude des
gouvernements de coalition l'enjeu
principal et dans le maintien soit de
votre coalition au pouvoir avec les
libéraux de votre parti démocrate les
socialistes de Paulette Lenert les
écologistes de Sam Tanson ou alors le
retour des chrétiens démocrate du CVS de
Luck Frieden ou tout autre coalition
d'ailleurs vous êtes très populaire à
titre personnel mais est-ce que mais
votre parti un petit peu moins est-ce
que vous serez en mesure selon vous de
former un nouveau gouvernement inchallah
on verra euh le le le le 8 on a les
élections j'ai jamais euh prédit des
résultats comme c'est un système de de
coalition euh ça fait 10 ans maintenant
qu'on travaille avec les deux autres
partis c'est aux électeurs de de décider
quelle politique ils veulent j'ai un
bilan qui je n'ai pas caché du bilan
qu'on a réussi à à effectuer mais ce qui
est intéressant bien sûr c'est aussi les
les programmes pour l'avenir et là je
dois vous dire qu'il y a beaucoup de
différence avec tous les partis qui sont
aujourd'hui en list et pour moi le but
c'est pas de rester Premier ministre
hein je dois vous avouer c'est bien sûr
mon ambition mais le but c'est de
pouvoir continuer une politique de
modernisation de développement
économique
d'égalité au niveau des impôts au
Luxembourg au niveau de la crise du
logement continuer la politique en
faveur de l'environnement ça c'est les
priorités si j'ai des partenaires qui
veulent pas le faire je préfère même pas
être Premier ministre vous pensez battre
le record de votre prédécesseur
justement Jean-Claude Junker 18 ans au
pouvoir et et d'ailleurs si ça n'était
pas le cas si vous n'étiez pas reconduit
est-ce que vous vous vriez comme lui
prendre un poste européen alors pour
l'instant mon ambition est de rester
Premier ministre granduchet de
Luxembourg je me suis pas donné comme
but de vouloir battre la longévité de
Jean-Claude Joker j'ai jamais eu
l'ambition de de le faire je serai là
tant que les électeurs veulent veulent
bien de moi c'est à eux de décider s'ils
veulent encore de moi du du stop ou
encore comme on connaît de la radio
c'est c'est leur choix Xavier betel vous
étiez la semaine dernière à l'Assemblée
générale des Nations unies donc à New
York devant laquelle vous avez parlé un
discours sur la solidarité le dialogue
et la tolérance qui n'est d'ailleurs pas
du tout passé inaperçu en raison de
cette sortie quand on voit aujourd'hui
qu'être gay lesbienne ou trans est
encore synonyme de condamnation à mort
je suis gay ce n'est pas un choix que
j'ai fait un matin quand je me suis
réveillé et que je me suis dit j'aime
les hommes le plus difficile a été de
m'accepter moi-même
être gay ça n'est pas un choix
être homophobe ça
l' voilà un discours prononcé d'ailleurs
il me semble sous l'œil de votre mari
qui était dans l'assemblée Xavier betel
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
l'homophobie progresse dans notre monde
le discours était ancré en fait sur le
fait que EN3 parce qu'on s'appelle les
Nations Unies en fait les droits ne sont
pas du tout unis et que le fait d'être
une femme dans un pays donne des droit
dans un autre pays donne pas de droit
d'être juif d'être catholique d'être
musulman ça dépend où on est d'être
d'une minorité aussi sexuelle euh aussi
et quand je parle des des des femmes
dans certains pays je tiens à rappeler
que ils avaient pas encore le droit de
passer le permis de conduire il y a pas
longtemps donc on voit qu'on a vraiment
des les les droits des uns et des autres
ne sont pas du tout les mêmes
l'homophobie c'est quelque chose que
j'ai vécu et je vis encore et c'est vrai
que aujourd'hui on on ressent qu'il y a
des relents mais c'est aussi de
l'antisémitisme he c'est de du racisme
on voit tout simplement que les les le
fait de
vouloir
gagner des voix sur les différences des
autres c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu dire
vous savez je suis pas devenu gay un
matin comme je l'ai dit à la tribune
c'est c'était pas écrit dans mon script
mais les gens pensent que c'est un choix
et que on peut changer ça quand je pense
que même certains pensent que il y a des
études qui permettre de médical qui
permettrai de de de de transformer les
homosexuels en hétérosexuels c'est c'est
pas comprendre que c'est tout simplement
un fait que c'est et encore moi j'ai la
chance de vivre dans dans un pays où ça
accepté mais même dans des pays ou des
capitales il faut pas oublier qu'il y a
pas que les capitales il a aussi les
villages et quand on voit le nombre de
jeunes qui se suicident parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à s'accepter eux-mêmes
mais quand je vois une jeune fill dans
certains pays qui chez qui l'avortement
n'est pas possible voyez j'ai certains
juifs qui ne peuvent pas vivre
sereinement des musulmans qu'il faut fa
exercer leur religion on voit tout
simplement que aujourd'hui dans le monde
selon où je suis né j'aurai des chances
d'éducation j'aurai des chances de santé
j'aurai des chances de vivre j'aurai des
chances de pouvoir vivre et j'ai j'aurai
la chance de pouvoir vivre en fait comme
je suis alors que le but des Nations
Unies c'est d'avoir des des droits qui
qui soient les mêmes pour tout le monde
et en fait c'est géométrie variable on
peut peut-être aussi balayer devant
notre porte
européenne parce que Victor Orban en
Hongrie est en croisade contre les
livres mentionnant
l'homosexualité en amont de ces
élections de ce weekend en Slovaquie la
rhétorique antigay a monté d'un cran et
puis en amont de d'autres élections en
Pologne dans 15 jours et bien les
ultraconservateurs multiplient les
procès contre les associations LGBT que
fait l'Europe finalement dire que
l'homosexualité il faut pas en parler
dans les livres qu'il y a même un un un
éditeur ou une librairie qui a eu des
sanctions en Hongrie parce qu'ils
avaient publié ou vendu un livre où ont
parlait d'homosexualité c'est c'est rien
comprendre vous savez quand j'ai eu les
discussions avec Victor Orban je lui ai
dit que c'était pas en regardant modne
FAM family que quelqu'un était devenu
était devenu gay c'est plus en regardant
même des séries et je veux pas être mal
compris mais sur si si la reine
impératrice d'Hongrie euh que on a
beaucoup fantasmé sur ses robes et ses
et c'est diadème sûrement certains des
uns et des autres donc arrêtons de de
penser que les clichés de de dire qu'on
parle d'homosexualité euh font des des
des homosexuels je trouve que c'est tout
simplement grave de vouloir stigmatiser
et quand je vois en Italie où on veut
tout simplement des droits qui ont été
acquis par des gens par des familles
homoparentales leur retirer ses droits
ou même les criminaliser et pénaliser et
quelque chose qui est quand même qui qui
va très loin et je je mais je trouve je
veux pas limiter mon débat vraiment à
l'homosexualité vous devez comprendre
tout simplement que aujourd'hui qu'on
soit homosexuel qu'on soit juif qu'on
soit d'une minorité qu'on soit noir
qu'on soit asiatique qu'on soit
aujourd'hui il y a un racisme qui existe
on le voit dans le foot regardez ce qui
s'est passé quand même il y a pas
longtemps lors d'un match de foot ce
racisme est quand même en train de
remonter et je pensais je penser qu'on
avait compris après ce qui séit passé l
de la deème Guerre mondiale qu'il soit
arrivé au pouvoir légalement je tiens à
le rappeler que Hitler a été élu été élu
démocratiquement VO le résultat surt une
augmentation de ces droites radicales
d'élection en élection qui n'apprécient
pas l'Europe communautaire qui veulent
l'Europe des nations qui se renforce
notamment en France avec Mar Marine Le
Pen mais en Italie avec une Georgia
melonie en Autriche en Allemagne que
pensez et comment contrer finalement ce
ce repli alors hier c'était les les
immigrés demain c'est les les les
homosexuels aprèsdemain sera les juifs
ils vont toujours essayer de trouver
quel sera le groupe qu'il faudra cibler
pour qu'il sera dans dans le trend alors
là ils essayent de de de de de
stigmatiser les uns demain ce sera les
autres et c'est ça ce que j'essaie de
faire comprendre que c'est pas bon et au
niveau européen je pense que ce que
faisait la commissaire jurova et ce
qu'elle fait encore aujourd'hui et de
respecter l'État de droit et d'insister
là-dessus et quelque chose qui est
primordial l'Europe n'est pas un tiroir
caisse ni un un self-sice où je prends
que ce que je veux mais je je je ne
respecte pas l'épine dorselle en fait
qui est pour moi de l'Union européenne
qui est celle aussi des droits parce
qu'au début c'est quand même un projet
paix c'est un projet de paix on doit se
rappeler que c'était après 45 en 57 la
volonté de construire une paix durable
parce que l'Union européenne c'est
mettre quand même les pays autour d'une
table qui qui ont des origines
différentes des cultures différentes des
langues différentes des croyances
différentes des traditions différentes
et c'est ça la richesse de l'Europe et
ce que certains autres essayent de faire
c'est c'est dangereux mais bon si s'ils
sont élus démocratiquement je je me
battrai en tout cas je me battrai de
tous mes mots de toute ma conviction
politique pour faire comprendre aux gens
que c'est c'est nocif c'est nocif pour
la santé c'est un peu c'est un peu c'est
c'est dommage mais il faudrait presque
le marquer comme sur les paquets de
cigarettes alors bon vous parliez de du
Projet de paix de l'Europe il y a en
attendant à nos portes une guerre en
Ukraine et d'ailleurs selon les derniers
les dernière données cette fois-ci de
l'OTAN l'Alliance atlantique votre grand
Ducher ne serait qu'à 0,72 % de dépenses
de défense bien loin des 2 % de PIB qui
est réclamé est-ce que vous ne souhaitez
pas renforcer euh votre armée dans ce
monde très dangereux on est un peu plus
on a commencé à 04 on va arriver à 1 %
on s'est engagé par rapport à ça mais
j'ai une armée au Luxembourg 2000
soldats alors si vous voulez que
j'arrive à 2 % je sais pas comment on
peut le faire et lors du dernier sommet
qu'on eu à Vilnus on s'est aussi trouvé
un accord avec les autres pays pour
avoir un mode de calcul qui soit
raisonnable par rapport à l'armée aussi
qu'on a et ce que l'on a quand même on
est parmi le pays je crois que pas loin
de 17 ou 18 % du budget luxembourgeis de
militaire et donné tout de suite à
l'Ukraine à l'Ukraine mis à disposition
de l'Ukraine donc je pense pas qu'il y a
autant de de pays qui fassent qui
fassent ça mais ce qui est important
c'est que vous me dites que je suis
peut-être pas beaucoup en niveau
dépenses mais je fais partie des rares
pays avoir 1 % aussi au grand duuchet de
Luxembourg qui donne à la coopération
qui investit en fait dans le
développement et on pense qu'ussi la
coopération c'est la
meilleure prévention aussi pour donner à
des jeunes générations aussi une
perspective d'avenir et que c'est très
important d'avoir ça je trouvra ça
regrettable de dire je coupe du la
coopération pour donner du jour au
lendemain plus à à en dépense militaire
mais on est en train d'augmenter et on a
trouvé un modus vivend c'est vrai que
votre grand Ducher a déboursé 188
millions d'euros pour soutenir l'Ukraine
et en même temps geler les avoirs russes
6,2 milliards d'euros détenus par des
personnes et antité ruses est-ce que il
y a débat au Luxembourg sur des
conséquences trop négatives notamment
pour votre secteur bancaire mais plus
généralement pour vos concitoyens de
cette guerre en Ukraine est-ce qu'il y a
débat sur son opportunité il y a pas de
débat mais ce qui se passe c'est qu'on a
on vit tous des conséquences de la
guerre en Ukraine nous avons une
augmentation des prix de l'énergie on a
bien vu qu'on était tributaire en fait
de la Russie au niveau du gaz première
chose mais ça nous a aussi motivé à
faire des économies d'énergie et on a
plus de 30 % si on regarde les citoyens
de de la consommation donc on sait quand
il faut faire des efforts les faire
ensemble et deuxième chose on a vu qu'il
est important aussi d'aller sur des
modes de énergie renouvelable qui est
quand même importante et arrêter aussi
les énergies renouvelables donc c'est
plus une motivation aussi pour changer
mais en tant qu'État ce qu'on a fait
c'est qu'on a mis un cap sur les prix de
l'énergie parce que de dire que après se
chauffer resterait un luxe et quelque
chose qui qui serait inadmissible mais
on doit investir dans le renouvelable je
pense que c'est aussi une des
conclusions des conséquences de ce que
l'on a appris au niveau guerre en Russie
mais on restera solidaire et solidaire
tout simplement parce que nous-même
Luxembourg on a été agressé deux fois
par des voisins plus grands et si il y
avait pas eu d'américain de Canadiens et
de britannique qui seraiit venu libérer
l'Europe je sais pas comment on serait
aujourd'hui parlons par exemple des
questions de glyphosate certains veulent
une pause environnementale et certains
veulent réintroduire en effet c'est
c'est votre cas d'ailleurs vous avez
réintroduit ce pesticide qui est très
controversé alors que vous aviez
vous-même interdit celui-ci est-ce que
est-ce qu'on est en train justement de
d'autoriser les pesticides pour 10 ans
de de faire une pause environnementale à
l'échelle européenne al vous m'avez dit
que je l'ai réintroduit non nous avons
une décision de justice qui a annulé la
décision DCIS d'interdiction donc c'est
la justice qui a décidé le la
réintroduction aussi du du produit et on
doit voir sur une base juridique comment
est-ce qu'on pourrait avancer mais ce
serait dans l'intérêt de tous qu'au
niveau européen par exemple le
glyphosate qu'prenne des des mesures
concrètes ça sert à rien que un pays
prenne juste la mesure mais nous on l'
prise c'était la volonté quand même de
ce gouvernement de vouloir aussi montrer
l'exemple là-dedans quand on sait quand
même que il y a des risques de cancer
avec certains produits aujourd'hui qui
sont sur le marché donc on doit quand
même avoir aussi un devoir de prévoyance
surtout qu'on sait qu'on peut faire
aussi autrement donc ça c'est un c'est
c'est c'est important et euh mais il y a
une décision qui nous a dit euh ça va
pas et État de droit donc je respecte la
décision de justice alors Xavier betel
au début vous nous parliez de 300000
personnes qui effectivement étrangères
vivent au grand Ducher notamment des
transfrontaliers de très nombreux
transfrontaliers euh plus de 5000
Ukrainiens accueillis par vous mais il y
a eu ce drame àampedousa avec des
dizaines de milliers de migrants en
quelques jours et là vous avez déclaré
que vous passez votre tour parce que les
capacités d'accueil du
Luxembourg ne sont ne permettent pas
d'accueillir et bien ces réfugiés là ça
ne vous ressemble pas non al première
chose alors juste pour préciser le pays
à peu près 3 660000 habitants et il y a
300000 320000 personnes qui sont non
luxembourgeoises dans ce pays donc ça ce
sont des gens qui vivent au grandch
Luxembourg nous avons aussi tous les
jours 200000 frontaliers qui viennent de
Belgique de France et d'Allemagne
travailler au granduchchet de Luxembourg
donc on a une population juste pour
expliquer pas que ce soit 50 % le tout
ensemble donc c'est 50 % de
luxembourgeois 50 % de non
luxembourgeois plus ou moins et plus 200
100000 frontaliers qui vienent
travailler tous les jours au Luxembourg
oui les réfugiés de l'ampodisa on l'a
toujours fait et vous savez j'ai vécu
ces moments où on nous téléphonait le
soir ce soit François Hollande que ce
soit Matthéo renzy qui m'appelé le soir
en demandant combien je pouvais prendre
de réfugiés j'ai l'impression que
c'était terrible parce qu'il y avait pas
cette solidarité le problème qu'il y a
aujourd'hui c'est que les structures
sont pleines pleines et si c'est pour
dire je prends quelqu'un mais il va
dormir dans la rue je peux pas
aujourd'hui c'est plein on est en train
d'essayer de trouver des structures
d'accueil euh on l'a montré avec les les
les les Ukrainiens on l'a montré à
chaque fois mais là c'est plein et donc
de donner l'impression je vais juste en
prendre pour que éviter que votre qu'une
journaliste me pose la question pourquoi
est-ce que cette fois-ci je passe mon
tour c'est plein plein plein plein plein
et si c'est pour dire venez chez nous et
puis vous dormirez vous vous débrouillez
c'est pas le but ce qu'il y a si des
réfugiés viennent ici on veut pouvoir
aussi les les recevoir au moins
dignement même si c'est pas parfaitement
mais au moins leur pouvoir leur offrir
une une structure actuellement c'est
archi bon mais on restera solidaire il
est important de le faire et je l'ai
toujours fait et je pense qu'il serait
temps aussi que certains autres pays le
fassent aussi merci Xavier betel de cet
entretien nous continuons d'ailleurs sur
le thème du pacte migratoire qui depuis
jeudi a avancé puisque l'Allemagne ne
bloque plus les discussions devraient
reprendre avec le Parlement européen
même si certains pays minoritaires ils
sont toujours hostiles on en parle tout
de suite dans notre partie
[Musique]
débat merci de nous rejoindre depuis le
Parlement européen à Bruxelles où la
question migratoire est sur toutes les
lèvres depuis l'arrivée de plus de 10000
migrants ces dernières semaine venu de
Tunisie sur la petite île de l'ampedusa
en Italie la première ministre italienne
Georgia Meloni est la présidente de la
Commission européenne Ursula van
derleyen se sont rendus sur place une
visite hautement médiatisée mais qui
masque mal l'impuissance de l'Union
européenne à gérer collectivement les
réfugiés im migrants tant la question
divise les partis politiques et les 27
oui alors dans l'immédiat la Commission
européenne a annoncé un plan en 10
points pour freiner l'arrivée des
migrants faciliter les retours et
surtout à débloqué 127 millions d'euros
dans les semaines à venir pour
précisément la Tunisie en situation
économique fragile reste que le pack
Asie lesmigration progresse avec une
attitude plus positive de l'Allemagne
même si certains pays il sont encore
très opposé l'appel lancé depuis
Marseille par le pape François qui a
dénoncé les tragédie des naufrages
provoqué par des trafics odieux le
fanatisme et
l'indifférence suffira-t-il à réveiller
les Européens alors pour en débattre
aujourd'hui nous avons en en présence
trois députés européens alors un Italien
j'ai envie de dire adopté par les
français puisque vous êtes élu sur une
liste française renw donc Sandro Godi
député européen pour la majorité
présidentiel donc mais également maline
Bork suédoise du groupe la gauche et une
Française maxette pierbacas élu en 2019
sur la liste du rassemblement national
mais aujourd'hui non inscrite toujours
souverainiste vous l'avez écouté le pape
il a raison de nous rappeler à notre
devoir d'humanité et de civilisation
tout à fait nous devons avoir cette
humanité puisque quand même c'est quand
même nous sommes des humains mais comme
je dis euh nous sommes pas mère thesa
aussi nous devons quand même par rapport
à nous en tant que moi députés
européenne ce PCT migratoire qu'ils
avaient qui voulaient mettre en place en
2020 ça aurait été déjà une solution
pour pouvoir déjà stopper cette
migration ce qui était normal
aujourd'hui faut pas que ce soit
peut-être que l'Italie et la Grèce qui
prennent cette pression au niveau de
l'immigration va falloir aussi que
d'autres État d'Europe prennent un petit
peu ce relais je sais qu'il y a à peu
près qui veulent qu' un peu
30000 migrants répartis dans plusieurs
États-membres pourquoi pas mais pour
l'instant trouver cette solution ça va
pas être facile ça va vous entendez
maline Bork euh quand quand 10000
personnes débarquent sur une île de 6000
habitants comme Lampedusa même avec la
meilleure volonté finalement euh on a du
mal à y faire face euh rappelons que que
120000 personnes ont débarqué depuis
janvier d'après la Croix-Rouge deux fois
plus que l'an passé euh que fait
l'Europe est-ce que est-ce que la
solution de dire nous sommes pas Mère
Teresa est suffisante non mais c'est ça
c discours là je peux pas entendre je je
dirais que j'étais à l'impedousin
j'étais à M j'étais dans les î Canarie
j'étais en Croatie j'ai j'ai été à
Lesbos et c'est pas facile c'est pas
facile il y a beaucoup d'arrivé et ça
montre sur ces point spécifique en
Europe et ça montre la la la nécessité
de mettre en place un système on partage
la responsabilité dès l'arrivée dès
l'arrivée et et et pour ça ça ça pas
changé et je je peine à comprendre
comment la Commission peut relancer des
stratégies qui n'ont pas marché jusqu'à
jusqu'à maintenant je dirais que de
essayer de bloquer des gens d'arriver
d'essayer de faire des accords avec des
des non démocraties que ça soit en
Turquie que ça soit en Tunisie
maintenant c'est pas c'est pas le chemin
le chemin c'est qu'on arrive à un accord
comment partager la responsabilité et ça
il faut le faire avant les élection 2024
Sandro Godi vous n'êtes pas le grand
supporter de la trait droitière pardon
diia mélonie présidente du conseil en
Italie mais en l'occurrence est-ce
qu'elle a raison de faire appel à
l'Europe melon est victime de son
nationalisme de sa propagande elle a
gagné les élections en disant qu'elle
aurait fait un blocus naval elle aurait
qu'elle aurait résolu au la main les
problèmes migratoirees depuis qu'elle
est arrivé au pouvoir les les les flous
ont doublé c'était 67 7000 en 2022 son
130000 cette année et main elle est
responsable de de doublement de ses flux
elle est responsable d'avoir d'avoir
fait de la propagande euh elle est
maintenant euh obligé à assumer ses
responsabilités par contre cette semaine
et on a discuté avec Emmanuel Macron qui
était à Rome pour les obsèques de
l'ancien président de la République
George Napolitano elle semble avoir
compris que sans Europe la souverainiste
nationaliste méogne elle semble avoir
compris que sans Europe elle pourra
jamais gérer les flux migratoires elle a
dit du bien de la France mais elle a dit
du mal de de l'Allemagne qui soit-disant
soutient les ongou oui mais mais parce
que elle cherche toujours en Albi un
ennemi extérieur elle a besoin de dire
qu' une semain c'est la FAU de la France
une semain c'est la FAU de l'Allemagne
le problème c'est qu'il y a des grosses
contradiction au sein du gouvernement
italien parce que la numéro 1 Georgia
Meloni maintenant elle parle de
solidarité européenne le numéro 2 Matteo
Salvini à lieu de Marine Le Pen il dit
la la migration c'est une question des
nations l'Europe n'a rien voir là-dedans
moi j'espère que l'Italie reprenne un
discours une action européenne parce que
seulement avec les partages du vardau et
seulement avec des actions communes
envers les pays d'origine aux frontières
communes et avec de la solidarité dans
les crises on peut gérer reprendre les
contrôles sur le flux migratoire madame
pierre bacas même même la droite un peu
radicale est très partagée sur cette
question du PACT migratoire et asile on
voit en effet une Georgia mélonie qui
est plutôt pour parce qu'elle fait
partie des pays d'arrivée d'autres comme
la Hongrie la Pologne qui veulent pas
entendre de parler de relocalisation des
demandour la Hongrie et la Pologne vous
le savez autant que moi vous savez qu'on
a donné quand même à la Tunisie 105
millions d'euros mais faut savoir même
si nous aidons ces pays mais quelquefois
ils font du chantage ils nous font du
chantage pour pouvoir refaire revenir
ces migrants nous trouvons trouver
concrètement d'autres solutions comme
madame la députée l'a dit mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui euh même monsieur le
Président Macron a dit au le
gouvernement français a dit monsieur
darmanet que ils vont pas accepter les
migrants de Lampedusa euh ça c'est clair
et no le 23 septembre sur BFM il a dit
la solidarité européenne elle est pas en
marche moi je crois qu'avec les chacun
pour soi on va il y aura des problème
problèm plus grands et plus gros pour
tout le monde donc il est clair que les
règles que nous avons maintenant les
celle qu'on appelle règ Dublin personne
les respecte l'Italie ne les respecte
pas parce qu'ils enregistrent pas à tout
ce qui arrive les autres pays ne la
respectent pas parce qu' ilsent pas une
solidarité aux Italiens aux maltais au
grec c'est pour cela que nous poussons
pour une nouvelle approche avec ces
nouveaux pactes sur l'asile immigration
qui pourrait finalement apporter des
réponses qu'on connais seulement on
s'est jamais jamais mis d'accord pour
les mettre en nouveau Pact he qui est
sur la table depuis 3 ans qui a été
présenté à l'automne 2020 par la
Commission européenne et impossible de
trouver une solution de relocalisation à
27 vous l'avez dit des pays comme la
Hongrie ou la Pologne ne veulent prendre
aucun demandeur d'asile et ne veulent
pas payer comment on sort de l'impince
maline B bon déjà il y a pas un vêau
hein donc il faut peut-être travailler
sur cette voie làà que il y a pas un ou
deux pays qui ont un véau sur cette
question il y a des règles pour prendre
des décisions au conseil mais c'est pas
consensus donc il y a 5 ans on a dit bah
comme la Pologne et Hongrie sont pas
d'accord on va pas y aller mais en fait
à la place on leur a donné tout le
pouvoir en fait de bloquer tout toutes
vous on passe outre finalement c'est de
oui je je vais vous dire que aujourd'hui
on a vu un autre exemple et je suis très
heureuse de qu'on a trouvé ça sur les
réfugiés ukrainiens et l'Europe a montré
bah c'est possible il a la volonté
politique on le fait avec dignité on
s'occupe des des des et surtout il y a
beaucoup des femmes et les enfants qui
arrivent on les met à l'école on
organise le vie il peuvent travailler
ilaccueille et Pronger et et ça se passe
bien il y a des améliorations à faire
mais ça se passe bien et à la place de
prendre ça comme modèle pour pour les
arrivé alors on se dit on va continuer
avec ce qui ne marchent pas qui produit
même la mort dans la Méditerranée avec
la la fermeture des frontières avec des
naval blockades de travailler avec des
dictateurs ou des non déémocraties en
dans les PI tiers des tiers pays et moi
je trouve ça c'est irresponsable vu
qu'on a un modèle qui est beaucoup plus
digne humainement et qui est aussi
possible en Europe au vous êtes d'accord
qu'on devrait qu'on devrait prendre pour
modèle finalement ce qui se passe avec
les raens c'est très différ alors
Caroline est-ce qu'on respecte déjà
l'espace Schengen non on ne respecte pas
déjà c'est un problème comme je dis on
dit les migrants mais ces gens-là ils
ont un rêve ils ont envie de de de de de
changer de mode de vie ils ont envie de
venir c'est pour ça je dis c'est c'est
très complexe aujourd'hui au niveau de
du peuple au niveau des immigrés
aujourd'hui pourquoi j'explique c'est
tout un problème politique c'est
politique aujourd'hui il faut la changer
comme je dis maintenant nous devons
trouver des solutions comme on dit aussi
c'est national mais aujourd'hui aussi
c'est européenne parce que nous devons
nous aussi les Européens de pouvoir de
stion quand on dit la Pologne je suis
désolé la Pologne aussi et l'Hongrie
font parti des 27 États membres ils
doivent aussi prendre leur
responsabilité vous ê pour ce mécanisme
de solidarité ch pays accue je suis pour
ce n'est pas que nous que la France que
l'Italie que la Grèce à pouvoir prendre
parce que nous aussi nous avons nos
problèmes d'immigrer aussi en France
nous avons ce problème aussi mais nous
lerons comme nous pouvons alors pourquoi
ne pas accueillir une partie des des
réfugiés ou des demandeurs d'asile
arrive à l mais vous savez que nous en
avion déjà assez pourquoi Monsieur
darmané vous dites que vous êtes pour le
mécanisme de solidarité
mais qu'on soit solidaire aujourd'hui
nous nous avons déjà que Ben la Hongrie
que la Pologne comme d'autres
États-membres prennent aussi leur
responsabilité est-ce ou on on est-ce
qu'on est assez solidaire en France on
sait que par relocalisation on a pris un
petit milliers de personnes maximum donc
c'est rappocalisation nont pas marché la
Suède a PR 5000 migrants demandeurs
d'asile de l'Italie l'Allemagne
4000 800 et la France 3800 donc la
relocalisation ça n'a pas marché euh là
par exemple à Lampedusa la présidente du
Conseil italien elle est victime de ces
contradictions parce que elle a été en
Europe l'allié des PIR ennemi d'une
solution européenne avantageuse pour
l'Italie parce qu'elle est l'allié des
Polonais et des Orban en étant la
présidente des SR elle a été juste
jusqu'à il y a quelques jours
l'adversaire de ces potentiels alliés
qui sont la France l'Allemagne les pays
qui en tout cas font même plus de
l'Italie pour ce qui concerne les
demandeurs d'asile parce que l'Allemagne
a eu plus de 150 250000 demandeurs
d'asile accueilli l'Italie 80000 donc si
un pays qui est décisif pour la question
migratoire comme comme l'Italie sort de
ces contradiction peut-être on pourrait
trouver un accord sur les contradic sont
pas qu'en Italie elles sont également
aussi dans d'autres pays comme
l'Allemagne qui a suspendu quelques
jours le mécanisme de solidarité
volontaire pour les demandeurs d'asile
sous la pression de l'extrême droite
avant de le remettre en place 2 jours
après fermer ses ses frontières en fait
c'est impossible maline Bork bah oui
évidemment que c'est impossible et je
veux dire toutes ces ces initiatives de
de faire des des accords avec des non
déémocraties et payer et mettre des que
ça soit des blocad d'autres de ça ça
marche pas donc la question c'est plutôt
comment on fait ça plus dignement et moi
je pense aussi pour euh un peu aussi
recadrer ce débat que c'est clair que
les réfugiés les migrants sont on les
jette de Pierr sur sur cette catégorie
de personnes et aussi pour éviter de
parler de d'autres choses on est dans
une Europe où les les sociétés sont
étirées où les injustices les les
inégalités économiques et sociales sont
tell et grandissante et donc dans
beaucoup de pays dans le mien la mien le
mien aussi la Suède la droite choisisse
d'un peu euh aller sur le terrain de
l'extrême droite et j'étais les pierres
sur les les nouvelles arrivées plutôt
que aussi de s'adresser aux problèmes
profonds qui se posent les gens dans
dans leur quotidien ça c'est ça c'est
pour moi c'est un V ce sont des bouqus
émissaires pour essayer de pas parler
des vrais problè je vais vous dire
Caroline pour moi aussi c'est un
problème qui est civilisationnel
pourquoi nous assoptons des Ukrainiens
qui sont chrétiens et pourquoi nous
assons pas des musulmans et des noirs
qui soort d'Afrique ah bah ça
ça r là moi je dis aujourd'hui moi je
suis fille d'immigré d'origine de l'Inde
colonisé par la France ces gens-là aussi
ils sont comme tous les autres c'est
pour ça nous devons
aussi prendre notre responsabilité mais
qu'aujourd'hui que la Tunisie ou la
Libye nous fasse du chantage aussi nous
pouvons pas accepter tout ce qui demande
aussi nous de vont agir agir autrement
c'est pour ça que je dis les accords
bilatéraux sol la solution c'est quoi
aucun de nous sait c'est quoi la
solution aucun député savent où nous
allons quelle est la solution dans la
gauche on a des propositions très
concrètes on a des propositions TR
concrètes alors justement l'autre piste
l'une des pistes pour l'Union européenne
pour freiner les flux c'est de
multiplier les accords bilatéraux vous
en parlez l'Union européenne avec les
pays de départ ou transit comme avec la
Tunisie sandrogisie très concrètement
est-ce qu'il faut les multiplier ces
accords moi je crois que la solution se
base sur trois axes les premiers oui
nous engager beaucoup plus avec les pays
d'origine on utilisant les visas en
utilisant les aides au développement en
utilisant les accords commerciaux pour
mieux les encourager à lutter contre les
trafiquants des êtres humains et à
coopérer aussi sur les retours deuxème
point gérer les frontières externes
telles qu'elles sont ce sont des
frontières européennes CE sont pas
seulement des frontière italienne
maltaise et grecque et dans du moment où
il y a des pics des des crises comme
celle de l'mé faire jouer la solidarité
mais c'est une sous-traitance qui a
quand même S qui est monayée parce que
les droits de l'homme est-ce qu'ells
sont bien respectés en Libye en Turquie
les réfugiés ils sont maltraités et
c'est c'est c'est peu de le dire on a vu
des images atroces c'est ça les valeurs
de l'UE non mais en fait l'Europe est en
train de se dévaluer au niveau des des
des pays dans le monde quand on fait des
accords avec des non déémocratie avec
des dictateurs parfois pour pourquoi
pour quelques milliers d'migrants c'est
ça je veux dire on est je veux dire on
en est où là et dans
V voà dans votre dans votre plan il y en
a faire des accords avec des
nonémocraties et euh fermer les
frontières avec beaucoup de muscles et
3è 3è c'est la solidarité pour la gauche
c'est facile la solidarité en premier et
pas cette militarisation moi j'étais au
gouvernement 4 ans et demi vous éz à
travailler sur laassuvetage des vies
dans la Méditerranée contre tous et tous
oui parce que à l'époque il y avait
personne qui nous faisait Cees discours
donc moi sur la c'est pas la solidarité
en 3è point c'est qu' une solution qui
qui demande vous l'avez dit pointhumité
demande de l'humanité c'est que nous
avons que mon gouvernement mon parti
politique a toujours démontré dans la
Méditerranée et je n'acccepte pas
d'avoir des leçons de votre part
là-dessus ça demande de la coopération
sur un pied d'égalité avec les pays
d'origine et ça demande aussi de
l'efficacité dans la gestion de la
migrationrégulires vous pas cont mais
c'est ça c'est ça la solution jusqu'à
quand on fera pas les trois choses on
continuera à laisser à laisser la
migration comme arme de distraction des
masses à l'extrême droite ce que vous ne
voulez pas et ce que moi je pas je veux
pas non plus nous aurons l'occasion d'
reparler d'ici les élections
européenness
animé4 de l'avoir de l'avoir très bien
incarné ici merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi vous restez bien sûr sur nos
antennes pour plus
d'informations
[Musique]